did Taylor Swift just shaved him pay at
the AMAs
Tayler kicked off the show with a giant
Cobra rising behind her and she posted
headlines that the snake stole the show
writing thank you for liking my duet
with Karen Karen is Taylor's name for
the giant snake that she also took on
tour and Taylor's use of that K name is
thought to be a dig at cam who implied
she was a snake during their 2016 whew
Taylor also posted this pic with a
pregnant friend backstage and described
herself as quote mother of snakes Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift won four AMA is
putting her total at 23 and breaking the
record for the most wins by a female
artist I'm even more excited about the
next chapter that comment sets Whitney's
into freakout mode fueling speculation
she's working on her seventh album and
Taylor doubled down on her promise to
inspire the youth boat and speaking of
empowerment
[Music]
JLo debuted her new fierce girl power
anthem limitless performing tonight
there were her sauce I saw a little bit
on Instagram I'm just so proud that I
get to do it the message view is really
about that there is no limit for women
and we go and we can do it all that's
right
it's very much the Jennifer Lopez it is
it is kind of my message as well but
that's the only thing holding you back
is you and taran killam jaw dropping
expression was all of us when new mom
car TV rocked the stage with her hit I
like it Carney she won three awards at
[Applause]
the head of baby
and speaking of hot mamas Carrie
Underwood with glam and oh yes you were
or just cradling your little baby we're
gonna break down all of the Nights
fashion coming up
[Music]
[Applause]